whether it's going back to the Black
Panthers the free speech movement occupy
Oakland we fight back hi I'm Zach why
smaller for reason TV we're here in
Oakland California in front of the
Emergency Operations Center building
which the city is planning to turn to
the domain awareness center surveillance
hub meant to watch over the entire city
I'm here with Ryan hofer he's an
attorney affiliated with Oakland privacy
working group which is challenging the
surveillance issues related to the
domain awareness center just give us a
rundown of what's going on here my
understanding is this started off as a
homeland security project to kind of
survey the port's into oakland and then
it morphed into something bigger what
exactly happened beginning back in two
thousand seven and eight the Department
of Homeland Security started handing out
funds Oakland received these funds to
secure port infrastructure that was its
sole purpose in two thousand nine and
ten suddenly due to some very large
mission creep this project began to
encompass the entire city of oakland
it's going to have cameras traffic feed
port cameras real-time video feeds
built-in of the 73 and fusion centers in
existence right now they're either city
only and there's just a handful of those
or their port as some of call that we're
going to be the first NSA municipal
outpost we are the first regional data
sharing entity within the city limits
oakland has high crime it's a way to
reduce crime it's a way for a law
enforcement to do things more
intelligently why are you against that
we've asked for a just one study that
shows that mass indiscriminate
surveillance reduces crime and no one
has been able to produce that data I
believe because it doesn't exist we have
approximately 7,000 documents in our
possession right now with over 3,000
emails and never once do they mention
homicide or rape or burglary murder
assault they're not talking about crime
so the purpose was was never about crime
so if they're not talking about crime in
these emails from between law
enforcement officials what exactly are
they you
using the surveillance for to monitor
protesters they're talking about Occupy
Oakland the protests that happened
during urban shield having the ability
to track people as they move around
downtown are you afraid that as this
grows bigger that that's where this is
going that it's going to be kind of
targeting political dissent right and
it's not just dissent its people of
color there was at one time a proposal
which at the moment we've successfully
defeated but to put cameras all
throughout Oakland Housing Authority put
cameras all throughout Oakland Unified
School District it's the young it's the
people of color Oakland is famous for
having a horrible relationship between
OPD and the citizens your group has
estimated about an 11 million dollar
price tag just to build this Center and
that money is coming from we should
mention federal grants from the
Department of Homeland Security how do
you come up with that price tag and what
are the kind of ongoing cost is going to
be be a little bit more precise 10.9
million and that's from the grants
themselves those are the numbers coming
out that have been approved there's five
phases of this project where each each
contract is worth X amount of dollars to
reach that 10.9 million dollar figure
this fusion center is funded by federal
dollars but it's run by local law
enforcement do you see anything wrong
with that kind of collaboration between
the feds and local on horse it's
absolutely a loss of local control we
were told last night by Michael Bryant
the port head that there is absolutely
an expectation of data sharing on the
feds part there are strings attached
this money does not come freely it is
not without cost right now this is still
in phase one which is primarily
surveillance of the pork the next phase
would expand that and start feeding
different cameras from around the city
license plate readers let's imagine a
future where this went forward and made
it all the way through phase five where
they have all the data that they want
going into the center what do you
imagine in Oakland's like that would
look
I think it would be amazingly conformist
the ACLU gave a great speech last night
on even legal activities are reduced in
frequency because you know you're being
monitored there was some Islamic
activists that spoke last night being
monitored especially post 9-11 reduced
attendance at their places of worship
you will only be comfortable doing
things in public which are on the phone
with a vanilla which which you feel
comfortable sharing with everyone there
won't be really that sense of personal
identity anymore because you will be
under surveillance 24 hours a day
everywhere you go fusion centers like
this are opening in cities across the
country Oakland seems to be the place
that right now is punching back the
hardest and has actually made some
progress to stop them is there anything
about this city about Oakland in
particular that you know has lended it
to be the one to fight back it's a
little bit gritty here whether it's
going back to the Black Panthers the
free speech movement occupy Oakland we
fight back and I think that's why we
became the first joint port municipal
project we were testing grounds let's
see what we can get away with in Oakland
well we're fighting back again as the
technology improves it's inevitable that
everyone including law enforcement is
going to embrace it it almost seems like
a given that we're going to be
surveilled do you feel like it's a given
or is it still worth it to fight these
battles I think it's absolutely was it
to fight these battles not just out of
my own self-interest 15 states have
introduced legislation brought basically
by the Tenth Amendment Center and Bill
of Rights Defense Committee to prohibit
use of state resources by the NSA
facilities within their states so I I
think the momentum is shifting the other
way the Snowden revelations in addition
to the other leaks have really shown us
it's time to turn this back obviously
this is not unique to Oakland these
centers are opening across the United
States all funded by the federal
government what does what happens here
in Oakland pretend for
the rest of the nation I think it will
provide a model for how to fight back
and hopefully eliminate these centers
there are 73 fusion centers around
America all DHS funded and if we show
that it can be done here it can apply
the law in their own state and turn this
around thank you very much for talking
to us it was a pleasure meeting you and
good luck with the fight for reason TV
I'm Zach why smaller